it called spider-man 3 because there are
three spider-men in the movie
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and
things are ramping
up with spider-man 3. yesterday we got a
teaser from an official
sony account and it teased all three
spider-man
appearing in spider-man 3 toby maguire
spider-man andrew garfield spider-man
and tom holland spider-man of course but
in the midst of all of the excitement
surrounding this teaser
a lot of people missed zendaya going on
the jimmy kimmel show and him
asking her about spider-man 3
specifically if tobey maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man were
going to show up in the movie so we'll
go over this interview and talk about
what was said be sure to subscribe if
you're new so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a
zombie mysterio funko pop picking a
winner on
friday so let's dive straight into it on
the jimmy kimmel show
jimmy kimmel says so you're in atlanta
right now filming spider-man 3
correct in which of course zendaya
replied correct
and then he said and you can say that
right because i know it's very secretive
in which zendaya replied yes everything
is very secretive
now of course they're talking about
marvel filming in general typically
everything is pretty secretive but jimmy
kimmel is also specifically talking
about spider-man 3 because we obviously
as a fandom
know all of the hype that's around it
right now but now the hype has gotten so
big
that even people outside of our fandom
people who are just kind of casual fans
are starting to hear that this movie is
going to be huge and could possibly
have more than one spider-man in it
which was seemingly confirmed in the
sony
video but then jimmy kimmel specifically
asked about the other spider-man he says
is it called spider-man 3 because there
are three spider-man in the movie
in which zendaya replies i can neither
confirm nor deny
is it called spider-man 3 because there
are three spider-men in the movie
i can neither confirm nor tonight you
cannot get oh interesting
now of course this is classic marvel
they can't really tell you anything
all of the actors who sign on for these
roles have to sign nda's non-disclosure
agreements meaning they can't say
anything about the film to the public
without marvel's permission of course
this is why so many actors in the past
even though they've already been cast
for roles still have to deny
that they have been cast for those roles
because they're not allowed to say so in
fact paul rudd went on some late night
shows and they would ask him if he was
ant-man and he would say no
even though at the time he already was
he just had to say no and that's a
similar situation that we have here with
zendaya
there's no way she can say yes toby
maguire and andrew garfield are coming
back for spider-man 3 there are going to
be three spider-man in the film
but of course her answer basically
confirms that there are she says i can
either confirm
nor deny not saying yes but not saying
no but then jimmy kimmel prize a little
bit more he says you had a thanksgiving
there
in atlanta and zendaya said yes we had a
bubble thanksgiving and then
jimmy kimmel said with spider-man and
then you can see zendaya about to say
yes but then she stops herself and says
uh i can't say that
jimmy kimmel laughs because he knows
that she was about to say yes and she
says you almost got me that was good
he continues to pry and says i know toby
maguire is a vegan so i was wondering if
he had like a tofurky or something like
that in which zendaya just says
i don't know and then he tries one more
time at the end he says true or false
zendaya
andrew garfield hates cranberry sauce in
which
zendaya just laughs and says i see what
you're doing here or false
zendaya um andrew garfield hates a
cranberry sauce
so the hype around spider-man 3 and all
the different spider-man around it is
getting
huge but also keep in mind that this is
kind of scripted everything kind of has
to be approved about to talk about
beforehand
because of course this is promotion for
spider-man 3. this is to get people
excited and interesting so now on live
tv on a show that
millions of people watch they are
talking about three different spider-man
appearing
in spider-man 3. so they are basically
in a very
indirect way promoting a spider-verse in
spider-man 3.
and it all seems very apparent now since
we got that little teaser from the sony
channel yesterday so
things are getting super exciting for
spider-man 3 as if they weren't already
but hopefully this weekend at cc xp we
can get something official from sony if
not hopefully by the end of the year
like they promised
i will link the full interview to this
down below so you can go watch it for
yourself i couldn't show the whole thing
of course due to copyright reasons but
go check it out for yourself but let me
know in this video what you think about
this interview
and let me know how excited you are for
spider-man 3 be sure to leave your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
yet
give the video a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it and if you want live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof